you said you were bringing a Modern Edge
to it on stage what do you mean by that
I just mean that it's no longer 1937 and
we absolutely wrote a snow white that is
not going to be saved by the prince he's
not gonna be saved by The Prince and
she's not gonna be dreaming about true
love she's dreaming about becoming the
leader she knows she can be and the
leader that her late father told her
that she could be if she was Fearless
Fair Brave and true and so it's just a
really incredible story for I think
young people everywhere to see
themselves in no white is running for
president
I'm launching my campaign do you see
this delusion it's like sweetheart the
only reason anybody cares what you have
to say is because you're pretty you know
what I mean like we we live in this
delusion where we care about a 21 year
old political opinion she's not smart
not intelligent he's just pretty